nos dicen el maíz se usa como alimento y
como insumo en la producción de etanol
un combustible alternativo supón que el
maíz se produce en un mercado de
competencia perfecta dibuja y etiqueta
correctamente las gráficas de lado a
lado del mercado de maíz y de un
granjero representativo en las gráficas
muestra lo siguiente el precio y
cantidad de equilibrio en el mercado de
maíz etiquetados como p sub m
m respectivamente la cantidad producida
de maíz que maximiza la ganancia y que
representa una ganancia económica cero
etiqueta la como q su eje como siempre
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
esto por su cuenta antes de que lo
resolvamos juntos muy bien vamos a
resolverlos juntos vamos a realizar las
gráficas de lado a lado y a etiquetar
las correctamente aquí está el eje
horizontal para la gráfica del mercado y
aquí está el eje horizontal para la
gráfica del granjero aquí está la
cantidad en el mercado y acá está la
cantidad para el granjero este eje es el
precio en el mercado y cualquiera que
sea el precio en el mercado también será
el precio que debe tomar el granjero
ya que nos dicen que el mercado es de
competencia perfecta el granjero aquí es
precio aceptante dibujamos este otro eje
este es precio y este otro también es
precio primero vamos a hacer la gráfica
del mercado la etiquetamos mercado de
maíz ya hemos hecho estas gráficas
muchas veces la curva de demanda se ve
así cuando el precio es alto hay poca
cantidad demandada y cuando el precio es
bajo hay más cantidad demandada la curva
de oferta se comporta de forma opuesta
por lo que se ve así el punto en donde
se intersectan estas curvas nos ayuda a
encontrar el precio de equilibrio p sube
m y acá abajo tenemos la cantidad de
equilibrio q sub m esta otra gráfica es
para el granjero la etiquetamos granjero
el granjero es precio aceptante por lo
que cualquiera que sea el precio de
equilibrio en el mercado también será el
precio que tendrá que aceptar el
granjero el precio del mercado también
es el ingreso marginal del granjero en
el inciso 2 nos piden indicar la
cantidad producida de maíz que maximiza
la ganancia y que represente una
ganancia económica cero
etiqueta la como q sub efe vamos a tener
una cierta cantidad de aquí que será la
que maximiza la ganancia pero también da
una ganancia económica 0 el tener una
ganancia económica 0 nos dice que el
precio debe ser igual al costo total
medio en dicha cantidad dibujamos una
curva de costo total medio que se ve así
y voy a hacer que el punto mínimo
interese que al precio del mercado
porque sabemos de vídeos anteriores que
la cantidad que maximiza la ganancia se
da cuando el costo marginal intersec a
el ingreso marginal que en este caso
será el precio que el granjero tiene que
aceptar del mercado y sabemos que la
curva del costo marginal intersec aa la
curva del costo total medio en este
punto mínimo dibujamos la curva de costo
marginal que se ve así la etiquetamos y
noten que la curva de costo marginal
intersec a al costo total medio en este
punto mínimo lo hemos explicado en
varios vídeos y explicamos en el vídeo
anterior que la cantidad que maximiza la
ganancia es la cantidad en donde
coinciden el costo marginal y el ingreso
marginal
recordemos que el precio es el ingreso
marginal más allá de ese punto cada
unidad adicional
por el granjero va a dejarle una perdida
pues le costará más recursos producir
esa cantidad de maíz de lo que va a
recibir en el mercado también nos dicen
que debe ser una situación de ganancia
económica cero por lo que el costo total
medio tiene que estar en ese precio
justo en el punto con el ingreso
marginal por lo que aquí tenemos a q sub
efe la etiquetamos con eso terminamos y
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo